WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi, everyone.
How are y'all doing?
We're having a good I/O.
So thanks for coming here.
So let's get started
with this session.
So our session, today, is all
about bringing Android apps
over to Android TV.
So my name's Wayne Piekarski.
And I'm a Developer
Advocate at Google.
And I work in areas like
TV and Cast in the living
room and wearables.
And my goal is to
communicate information
about these products
to developers,
but also to talk to
you more, and find out
about what your needs
are, and feed them back
to the product teams.
RYAN SEYS: So I'm Ryan.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer at Google.
And I build things
for you guys, you
developers-- things like
tools, API client libraries,
and samples, just to make
your lives more productive.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Today, we're going
to assume that you have
some knowledge about Android
development because the goal
is we're going to teach you
how to take your apps and how to
get them working on Android TV.
So what's the motivation
for this talk?
Well, I've been talking to
lots of developers out there.
And I say, hey, have you
done an app for TV before.
And they're like,
oh, you know, I
don't think this is
something I can do.
It's too much work, or whatever.
And it turns out
that most developers
aren't fully aware of
how similar Android
TV is to Android itself.
So I thought, wouldn't be great
if we did a talk about this
and to show you the
small steps that
are needed to get your
app on to the big screen?
So if developers aren't doing
this, why is this a problem?
Well, right now, there are
millions of Android TV devices
that are activated
out there right now.
And the number keeps
going up every day.
You can buy TVs with
Android TV included.
You can buy little
set-top boxes that
include Android TV, as well.
And they're really
cheap and affordable.
And a lot of people have these
devices in their living rooms,
now.
And these customers
are looking for apps
to use on their devices.
So the important thing
here is that, if you
go to an Android TV device
and start up Google Play,
not every app in the Play Store
will appear on your device
immediately.
It turns out, as a
developer, you actually
need to take a few small
steps and tell Google Play
that your app is ready for TV.
And then, it will make
your app available.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today.
We're going to show
you how to do this.
And the good news
is that Android TV
is really easy to develop for.
And so to quote my very
famous colleague Ryan, here,
"it's just Android."
And so it uses the same SDKs,
the same tools that you're
familiar with, same Android
Studio, and the same emulator
tools.
So you can get
started really easy,
if you're familiar with
Android, right now.
And so the basics are you got to
tweak your manifest file, check
a box in Google Play, and
then your app's ready.
So that's the really
cool thing about it.
And that's what we're
going to talk about, today.
So the other thing is
that you can actually
make a single APK that you
upload to Google Play that
supports both TV and phone.
That's how similar
these things are.
So the first thing with this
talk that I wanted to point out
is that a lot of
people think, well,
Android TV is only useful for
watching TV shows and movies.
But I really think
there's so much
more possibilities
for what you can do
rather than just those things.
So imagine you could
browse photos and artwork,
you could look at
restaurant menus, or houses
that you're looking to buy, or
exploring maps, or 3D models,
or playing computer games.
So there's a whole bunch of
possibilities that really
make the possibilities endless.
And so Android TV
really breaks down
the possibilities
of what we thought
TV could be used for into
so much more other things.
And the other thing is that
Android TV is the largest
screen in your house.
Every house has
this massive screen
that's in the living room,
in the center of the house.
And so it has huge possibilities
for what you can do with it.
And so that's what we're
trying to encourage today--
is for developers to think
of new platforms and new ways
of taking their apps
and getting them out
to consumers out there.
So today, we're going to help
you redefine what a living room
experience could be and
really create amazing apps.
So I'll hand it
off to Ryan, now,
and he's going to go through
some more of the steps of how
to do this.
RYAN SEYS: Thanks.
So the first step in bringing
your app to Android TV
is you're going to need
to add a TV banner.
This banner is going to provide
the launch point for your app
on the Android TV launch screen.
So here's an example
banner that I've
taken directly from
our sample app, which
is available on GitHub.
Here is our sample banner
alongside some official Android
TV apps.
This is what it would appear
like on the Android TV launcher
itself.
So there are a
couple requirements
that we would like
you to follow when
you're creating your TV banner.
The first is that the banner
should be 320 by 180 pixels.
That's because Android TV--
this is the size that it's
going to display it at.
And if you make your
banner any other size,
it's just going to stretch
it and skew it in a way
that you wouldn't really like.
The second is that your app
name should appear readable
in the banner itself.
And the reason for
this is, on Android TV,
the name of your
app doesn't actually
appear below the banner.
And so we ask that you
put it inside the banner
itself so that your
users can understand
what app they're clicking
on when they open yours.
So it's super simple to add.
It takes a single
line in your manifest.
I'm sure you're
familiar with this.
In your application tag, just
add android:banner attribute
and point it at your
drawable resource.
Super easy, right?
So if you did all this and
you tried to run your app,
nothing would actually happen.
Just setting this banner
doesn't get your app
running on Android TV.
And so, next, I'm
just going to talk
about how you would declare
the activity to launch
when you click on the banner.
So let's jump into it.
So here's an activity.
This may be your main activity
in your Android manifest.
And you have an
existing intent-filter
there with the action, MAIN,
and the category, LAUNCHER.
So here we're just going to
add a second intent-filter
to your existing activity
with the category,
LEANBACK_LAUNCHER.
The reason that we
actually separate
LAUNCHER and LEANBACK_LAUNCHER
is because our best practices
is that you're going to
create your own TV specific UI
and layouts, eventually.
However, for the purpose of this
talk, we're just going to say,
why not get started, throw
it in your existing activity,
and see how much it works.
Like I said earlier,
it's just Android,
so you'd be surprised
by how much works
right out of the box.
The next big difference
on Android TV
is the TV hardware itself.
So mobile devices-- they
can make phone calls.
They can take photos.
They use NFC.
They have touch screens.
TVs don't have any of
these things-- at least
my TV doesn't have
a touch screen.
And so for these
reasons, we actually
need to tell Android that
these features that we
may have come to
expect on a phone
will not be available on a TV.
So the way that we do this is
through our uses-feature tag.
And you guys, I'm sure,
are all familiar with this.
You declare the hardware
features that you would like
to use in your app manifest.
And this is probably fine.
For phones and tablets,
it's going to automatically
set required to true.
However, for Android TV and
for TV hardware specifically,
this hardware might not
be available on TVs.
And so we need to update
that to required="false"
so that the TV itself
knows that, hey,
I can still operate without
this hardware requirement.
So one gotcha, actually, is
that the touchscreen hardware
requirement is, by
default, required="true"
even if you don't
declare that you need it.
And so we actually need to take
this snippet that you see here
and add it directly right
into your Android manifest.
So another gotcha is that
some permissions, actually--
if you asked for, say, a
RECORD_AUDIO permission.
It's actually going to imply
this hardware requirement
for a microphone.
And this makes sense, right?
You want to be able to
record some audio so you're
going to need a microphone.
But you might not
actually declare
the uses-feature itself.
And so what we have to
do to get around this
is just go into your
Android manifest,
declare uses-feature tag,
and set required to false.
So this is the
most important part
about bringing your
app to Android TV.
This is the UI
navigation and controls.
So with no touch screen
available on TVs,
we have to rely on
these minimal controls.
And this is what
brings us to the d-pad.
So the d-pad, which also
stands for directional pad,
is the de facto way to
navigate on Android TV.
Now, this d-pad is not
an entirely new idea.
Some of the first
phones actually
used d-pad for navigation.
And when we say navigation,
what we're really talking about,
here, is this intuitive
change of focus.
Touch screens have
revolutionized our ability
to tell our
interfaces, when I tap,
here, I want you to
focus and take action
at that specific point.
However, on TVs we don't
have this same luxury
because there's no
touch screen available.
So in order to focus,
what we need to do
is progressively shift our
focus from element to element
through our UI until we get
to the one that we want.
And on Android, there are
a number of different ways
that focus is handled
and manipulated.
And so I'm going to discuss
each one of these briefly.
So the first thing that you need
to know about focus on Android
is this attribute
called focusable.
And I'm sure you're
all familiar with this.
In simple terms,
though, on Android TV,
your users are going
to be using a remote.
So with any element that you
want them to interact with,
the element itself
should be focusable.
And to do that, all we do is
we set this focusable attribute
to be true.
So as an example
use case here, where
you may be creating some
custom playback layout,
and it has a
play/pause button here,
which we've represented
with an ImageView.
And you're going to want
to be able to navigate
to that play/pause button
so that you can eventually
click it.
So all we do is we just
set focusable to true.
Now, one thing to
keep in mind here--
a little bit of a
gotcha-- is that some
views-- they don't set
focusable to be true by default.
ImageView is one of these.
So in this case, we have to
set it explicitly to true.
Great.
So now, we can focus and
select our play button.
But what if we want to, say,
press right on the d-pad
and have it focus on
the fast forward button
or press left and have it
focus on the rewind button?
So we use these two
other attributes,
nextFocusRight
and nextFocusLeft.
So by setting these two
attributes as shown here, now,
Android is going to switch
the focus automatically
when you press those
buttons on the d-pad.
So there may be
other times where
you want to create your
views directly in Java code.
And so specifying
this focus in the XML
is not going to be
available to you.
For example, you may be
generating a lot of views,
like a grid shown here.
And you're not
going to necessarily
be able to declare exactly
what I should be focusing on
at that specific point.
So we need some way to ask
Android to change this focus.
And we do that through this
requestFocus method, which
is available on the View class.
So requestFocus just
does exactly that.
It requests-- it asks Android
to bring that view into focus,
if it is focusable.
And that's a key point,
if it's focusable.
Make sure that that
View is focusable
set to true before you
requestFocus or else
it won't do anything.
So the last thing that I'd like
to discuss here about the d-pad
is what if you want to take
some arbitrary actions when
any key is pressed.
So to do this, we're going
to override the activity's
onKeyDown method.
This method fires
when any key is
pressed that isn't already
handled by one of these views
inside of your activity.
So an example here
is that you could
combine this onKeyDown
with requestFocus
to change focus when
any key is pressed.
Or, a really common use case
is, if I press play/pause button
on the remote, it's going
to play-- I'm going to play
or pause my video.
Or, if you're making a
game, like I'm showing here,
maybe when you press
the right d-pad button,
you're going to move
your player to the right.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So Ryan
talked you through a little bit
about focus, and moving
things around, and so forth.
Now we're going to talk
a bit about the screen.
So it turns out, with
televisions nowadays, they
don't operate in the same
way that we would expect.
You would think that if
you've got a 1080 HDMI signal
and you feed it
through to a screen
that you would get a
one-to-one mapping.
It turns out that's
not quite the case.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about something
called overscan protection.
So if we actually
go back in time,
back in the days
of analog TV, there
were these edges on the
screen that were not used.
And TV stations actually used to
embed little signaling and bits
of data and things like that in
that area that wasn't displayed
with the television.
It turns out that,
when we moved to HD,
that stuff still happened.
And so a lot of TV manufacturers
will actually take a TV image,
and they'll chop off the edges,
and then stretch the image
slightly so it fits the screen.
So what this means is that you
don't get a one-to-one mapping.
And some of the pixels on the
edge actually get chopped off.
So you can disable
this on some TVs.
There's overscan or some
other feature like that
that you can remove
with the remote.
But a lot of users
don't know how to do it.
So you need to be
aware of the fact
that there are some
people out there who
are not going to see the edges
of the screen of your app.
And so we need to go about
dealing with that somehow.
And so, if we look
at this diagram here,
you can see that we have
our 1080p overall display.
And we've also shown it in terms
of dps, which is device pixels.
And then, you can show the
areas that are not included.
And we have a
guideline, which is
that you should roughly
stick to not using
the outer 5% of the image.
And that's usually a safe thing.
So if we look here, you can
see we've got some UI elements
and we've got the
edges protected
so that we don't use them.
So once again, a 5%
outer area is something
that you should reserve
that your app shouldn't
put anything important in.
Now, if you have a
background image, that's
OK if that gets cropped
because it's just-- probably
the interesting part is in
the center of the screen.
So background images
can get cropped,
but important pieces of text,
labels, any kind of import
information like
that-- you've got
to make sure that you keep
it out of that region.
And so here, we have a custom
layout XML that we're showing.
We've got two relative layouts.
And the inner relative
layout, if you look at it,
is padded with a 5% margin.
So you can see we're setting
margin top, bottom, left
and right.
And we've set dp values
that represent that margin.
And anything we put inside
that inner relative layout
will not be cropped off by
the television for any reason.
Anything else that
you don't care about,
like the background image
we talked about earlier,
you can put that in the outer
relative layout at the top.
And that will possibly be
cropped by the television.
So this is pretty
easy to implement.
And it's not really a huge deal.
But it's just something
you got to keep
in mind so that you make
sure it works for all users.
Next, not everyone
programs their Android TV
apps using Android
APIs directly.
So there's actually a
cross-platform gaming engine
called Unity that's quite
popular amongst game
developers.
And so the good news
for Unity developers
is that it actually supports
Android TV out of the box.
So Unity has support
for the d-pad.
So all that stuff
Ryan talked about
with handling the
controls, that's
already dealt with for you.
And it deals with all
the manifest tweaks,
and overscanning,
and making sure
that everything's done right.
So there's actually a Codelab
we've prepared for Android TV.
So if you go behind
this auditorium,
there is a Codelab
area where you
can go, and sit down, and try
out code, and mess around.
We have a Codelab for
Unity there as well
that you can give a try.
So that's the nice
thing-- is that a lot
of these extra tools
and so forth support
Android TV out of
the box, as well.
So if you've got a game that
does 3D and OpenGL and all
that, it just works.
So now, we'll go to
Ryan to talk more
about the Leanback
Library, which
is a very popular way of
implementing really nice TV
UIs.
RYAN SEYS: Thanks, Wayne.
So at Google, were trying
to make your lives easier
as developers.
And we know that
you don't really
want to implement all
this stuff yourself.
And so to help out, we
created that Leanback Library.
It has a great selection
of UI components
that are specifically
designed for Android TV.
And these components
come with support
for d-pad as well as
overscan protection
already baked right in.
So now, I'm going
to step through some
of these components
and explain why you may
consider using this library.
So the first component
here that I want to discuss
is this BrowseFragment.
The BrowseFragment is good
for-- well, browsing, right?
It allows you to showcase all
of your content in one place.
And so one of the best places
to use the BrowseFragment
is immediately when the
user opens this app.
So here's an example of
it being used in practice.
This is what it looks like being
run in our Leanback sample app,
available on GitHub.
And you can see
here that there's
a sidebar with some header rows
and a main grid of content.
So if you jump into a category
by pressing right on the d-pad,
you can see a more detailed
view of this content.
Here, we show some
thumbnail images, and title,
and category.
These can be basically
whatever you want.
You could display a
rating for your content.
You could display a price--
anything that you can imagine.
So if you select on
one of these cards,
then that brings us
into another fragment
that we call the
DetailsFragment.
So the DetailsFragment
presents all
of the details for a
specific piece of content.
It allows your users to take
certain actions-- anything
that you can imagine
like watching renting,
buying, this piece of content.
So again, here it
is in practice.
And you can customize, of
course, all of these colors,
text, buttons, to provide
a personalized experience
specific to that
piece of content.
So in this case, with
our New Dad video,
we can click WATCH TRAILER.
And then, we get
into another fragment
that we call the
PlaybackOverlayFragment.
So this provides a large,
customized controls
that overlay on top
of the media itself.
It also provides
an at a glance view
of what's currently playing.
So again, here it
is in practice.
It has a primary row,
which provides things
like play, pause,
rewind fast forward,
next video, previous video,
as well as a secondary row,
such as closed captioning,
picture-in-picture.
Here, I'm showing
some thumbs up,
thumbs down, and some
repeat functionality.
And then hidden at the bottom
there is a related videos row.
This is just a
place that you can
place related content to
whatever is currently playing.
And so this could be where
you recommend the next video
to play for your user.
So if the users can't find this
next great piece of content
to absorb in this
related video list,
then maybe search is
the next best thing.
And being Google, we want
to provide a great search
experience.
And so we've added
the SearchFragment
to the Leanback Library.
And so here again
is it in practice.
And we're searching
for the word "search."
And I think the best feature
of this whole SearchFragment
is speech recognition
capability.
So you can use the
microphone, which
is baked right into the
Nexus Player remote,
to speak whatever you want
and have it immediately fill
in the field.
So in addition to
in-app search, you
can also integrate with
this Universal Search.
So this is when a user searches
from the main TV launcher
for some related content.
And that will get
[INAUDIBLE] automatically
by the Android system.
So you can imagine you get
home, you turn on the TV,
and you search "funny movies."
If your app has
some funny movies,
you're going to want to
surface that to the user.
And so, to integrate
with search,
there's just a few things
that you need to do.
The first is implementing
a ContentProvider.
And you might already
have one of these.
Maybe you're already using
one for your in-app search.
And so, you can see
our documentation
for all the specific
rows that we support.
But the key thing here is that
the provider that you create--
you should set this
attribute exported="true"
so that Android has access
to it and can query it when
a universal search is made.
And then the next thing
is this searchable XML.
And again, you
might already have
one of these implemented
in your app already.
And so what you need
to do here is just set
this includeInGlobalSearch
attribute to true
so that Android, again,
can access this content.
So even before search,
your app might actually
have a good idea of what
the user wants to see next.
And so Android TV has this
powerful way that we can help,
which we call Recommendations.
So this Recommendations Bar
is featured front and center
as soon as the user opens
up their Android TV.
Android goes through
each app and asks,
hey do you have any
recommendations that you'd
like me to present to the user?
And so it takes all of
these from each app.
And it merges them together.
And so when a user clicks
on a recommendation, which
would appear in this bar, it
will immediately open your app
to that piece of content.
So here are a few
recommendations
on what you may want to
recommend to your users.
The first is
continuation content.
A good example is the
next episode in a series,
as well as new content--
things like new episodes
or a new series
altogether, as well as
popular or trending content.
And then, related content.
This is things like based
off the user's viewing
history or behavior.
And so all of these
UI and fragments
that we've shown
you today-- they're
available through the Leanback
and Recommendation Support
Libraries, which, if you're
using Android Studio, which
we highly recommend, you
might be familiar with Gradle.
Of course, we support
these Gradle dependencies.
And so you just you
drop these two lines
into your build.grade.
And Gradle will handle
everything else.
Wayne?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
So one common thing
I hear from developers
when they're
asking about Android TV
is they're like, oh, hey,
I can't develop for
Android TV because I
don't have a device on my desk.
And so while it's
nice to have a device,
you don't actually need
one because the emulator
is actually available to
help you do your testing.
So a lot of people
think the emulator also
isn't good enough.
But it turns out that the
emulator in Android Studio
is actually really good.
And so for Android TV,
we've done a lot of work
in improving its performance.
And so it's actually really nice
to use this for development.
And so what we're
going to do now
is we're going to show
you a quick little demo.
So they're going to bring
it up on the screen there.
This is Ryan's laptop running
the emulator, right now.
And so this emulator
here is the x86 variant.
So it's very
important that you run
x86 when your on
an x86 laptop so
that it doesn't have to
emulate everything completely.
And it's also important that you
have the HAXM driver, as well.
So we can see here is Ryan's
running the sample that I'll
give you the link to later.
But the sample has a
series of video clips
and he's browsing
around fragments.
And so do you want to
fire up a video, Ryan?
So this here shows video
playback happening.
So it's streaming the video.
It's decoding it, playing
it back within the emulator.
So as you can see here,
it's very performant.
It's decoding the video in
real-time on his laptop.
And so the emulator
is quite useful.
Also if you look on the
right of the screen,
there is the extended controls.
So an Android TV has its
own remote with left,
right, up, down, but it
also has back, pause, play,
and so forth.
All of those controls are
available on the emulator,
as well.
So you can simulate
every single button press
and check that your code has
all the right d-pad support
and things like that because
not every button necessarily
is mapped to the keys.
So the great thing is
that this simulator does
all of the buttons that are
available on regular devices
and you don't need to purchase
a physical Android TV device.
So this is pretty cool.
If you're interested
in doing this,
you should grab the sample, fire
up the emulator, try it out.
And then, when you're
ready, you can publish it.
And your app will works really
well on real devices, too.
So once you've built
your app-- so we've
gone through all the different
little manifest tags and things
like that.
We're now at the
point where we need
to talk about publishing
you app to Google Play.
So we have the--
RYAN SEYS: If we could
go back to the slides.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Oh, yeah.
If we could flip
back from the-- OK.
Great.
Thanks.
So now, we're going to talk
about how to get your app
and publish it to the console.
So if we go to this
slide here, you
can see a screenshot
showing what the developer
console looks like.
So this is the same place where
you upload your regular APKs
that you're uploading
from mobile.
And there is an option in
device categories where it says,
Android TV.
And if you look right
at the bottom there,
there's a checkbox
that says distribute
your app to Android TV.
So by default, that
box is not checked.
So if you want your app to
be visible on TV devices,
you have to check
that box, as well.
That then declares to the Play
that your app is ready for TV.
And there is a few
little conditions there.
And you can click on
that Learn more link
to find out more about
what the requirements are.
So you submit your app.
It gets approved.
And then after that, it will
then be available for people
to find on Android TV devices.
And then, they can
go to the Play.
search for your app
by speaking or typing it in.
And then, they can
install it, just
like they would on a phone.
And updates are rolled out in
the same way, and everything
like that.
So it's a pretty easy
and painless experience.
And as I said earlier,
you can either
have a single APK
that contains all
of the resources and activities
for both phone and TV.
Or, you can have
separate APKs where
one has the resources
and everything for TV
and the other one has for phone.
What you do is going to be
dependent on who your target
market is and how concerned
you are about download sizes
and, also, how much
difference there
is between the TV
and the phone app.
If there's no differences
in the resources,
you can just do a single APK.
So we've gone through some
guidelines in this talk.
The guidelines are
actually referenced
in the documentation.
And there's actually
a link here,
on developer.android.com, which
has a complete checklist of all
of the things that are important
to get your app approved to be
distributed on Google Play.
Now it's important that
you get your app approved
because, if it's rejected,
it won't be visible.
So it's very important
that you actually
think carefully about
each of the guidelines
to minimize the amount of time
it takes for you to get it
on Google Play.
So let's quickly walk through
them and summarize quickly
what they are.
So Ryan mentioned
earlier, you need
to have a LEANBACK_LAUNCHER
in your Android manifest.
This declares that your
app is ready for TV.
And it says what the
activity is going
to be when someone clicks
on your app to start it up.
You need a banner image that's
320 by 180 at xhdpi resolution.
If you don't use
that resolution,
it'll be resized for you.
You need to eliminate
requirements
for any unsupported hardware.
Remember, TVs don't
have touch screens,
so you need to have
touchscreen="false".
And any other
requirements you have,
like if your app
uses GPS, you're
going to have to set
that to false, as well.
And make sure that, if your
code is doing something
like grabbing a location,
check for errors
to make sure that you don't
accidentally fail and throw
an exception.
So as part of the new transition
to the new permission model,
apps have to check a lot
more for these things.
The same kind of thing here.
You got to make sure you
don't expect a device
to be available when it's not.
Next thing.
Ensure any permissions
you add don't add
hardware requirements, as well.
Certain permissions, like
RECORD_AUDIO that Ryan showed
earlier, also have requirements
that you have to manually set
to required="false".
Next, you can't assume that your
app is running on a portrait
device-- like a phone runs
as a portrait orientation.
And some apps lock
themselves so that they
don't run in landscape mode.
It's very important, because
the TV is a landscape device,
that your resources are
configured correctly
for screens like that.
Next, you really need to
think about viewing everything
from a distance.
So this is no longer
something that you're running
very close to your face.
It's running on a screen.
It's very far away in
someone's living room.
So you really need to
think of large fonts,
and easy to read text,
and large images.
And you should test it.
So try to step back
from the screen
and check that it's actually
readable from a distance
like that.
Some people have poor vision.
They're not going to read
super tiny writing like that.
Next, make sure you
think about overscan.
We talked about that before.
Make sure you don't put anything
important within the outer 5%
of your screen.
And so, lastly, think about
implementing the Leanback user
interface.
So if you've got an
app that's like a game,
you probably don't need to.
But if you're building
some kind of browsing,
something that goes through
media, or food, or pictures,
or photos, make
sure that, if you
want to really make it integrate
into the Android TV experience,
that you use the Leanback
Library because the Leanback
gives a consistent UI
across the whole device
that it will look the
same between other apps
and also with the
Android TV system itself.
So those are the guidelines.
And that link up there is
available in the documentation.
You should definitely
look through them
when you're getting ready
to publish your app.
So that was a really
quick overview
of how to bring your
app over to Android TV.
So I hope you found it
inspiring and it gave you
some ideas as to how to
think about taking your app
and what would be involved
in making the change.
It's not really hard to do.
It's just a few little things.
So how do we get
started with this?
Well, the first thing is
the talk's being recorded.
So if you want to review
everything later on,
you'll be able to go back
and go through everything.
But we also have a lot of
other great resources, which
are shown on the slide here.
So the first thing we have
is the documentation site.
So on
developer.android.com, we've
got training guides
that give an overview
and summarize some of the
things we've said today.
And we also have
the Leanback sample.
So it's on GitHub.
In the Google Samples.
It's called Android TV Leanback.
And that demo that Ryan showed
earlier is that sample there.
So you can play with it,
see how the videos stream.
See how it works for you.
And it's a really great way to
see how a well-built app works.
And you could probably tear
it apart and put your own code
in there and so forth.
The next thing I mentioned,
we have the Codelabs
in the other area, where
you can go over there
and you can try out.
You can sit down, play
with some devices.
And there are actually
engineers on staff there
who can help answer
your questions, as well.
And we also have the sandbox.
So there is an area over there
with these large metal box
crate things that we have
an area showing TV and Cast
devices.
Feel free to come by there.
And we have people who work
on the actual Android TV
team ready to answer
questions there, as well.
And also, people like me
and Ryan will be there, too.
So we're getting to
the end of the day.
So there's not too
much time left.
But please, do come
by after the talk
and come have a chat with
us because the whole point
of Google I/O is we want to
share information with people
and get information
from developers.
If you've tried to do Android
TV and something didn't work out
for you, come and
tell us what happened
so that we can think
about it and, maybe,
come up with a solution for you.
And finally, for people who
can't come here or for later,
we have a great developer
community on Google+.
So the link is
g.co/androidtvdev.
And it's a great place where
we post articles about what's
coming up, what's new.
And also, it's a place where
you can ask questions and chat
with other developers.
And definitely, I
recommend you follow us
because I post a lot
of articles about TV.
But also, I do
wearables, and auto,
and all these other things.
And there's a lot of commonality
between the platforms
that Google offers.
And so, if you've
got a phone app,
you should consider
TV, and auto,
and wearables because these
are all new, exciting platforms
where users are waiting for
really cool and exciting apps.
Thank you very much for coming.
And we'll see you later.
RYAN SEYS: Thank you.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]